okay let's go ahead and get started as a
few of you know today's the second
proposal defense new track although
there's a few a few of us who managed to
to attend both both both of these talks
anyways today is Nathan bars
dissertation proposal defense and the
purpose of these sessions is for him to
present his proposed work to us and we
comment on it and then when we're done
we leave him to his committee and they
may have further questions and comments
and ultimately decide whether he's ready
to go forward so nathan has been a
fixture around here for a while he got
his master's degree here prior to that
he received the bachelor's degree in
bioinformatics from UC Santa Cruz but
he's in the clinical informatics track
now and he will present his talk for
those of you who are in X I guess is
mostly regulars here but when you ask a
question push down on the button so it
gets recorded and also streaming this
over the web so it's all yours Nathan so
my topic is about measuring team
cognition in a clinical activity system
one of the reasons I wanted to explore
this topic is that when we implement
complex technology like electronic
health records or even change the
process there aren't that many good
tools or instruments that can measure
the impact on that of that process on
team behaviors or the implications that
have that it has for clinical team
performance so I'll just wait a few
seconds or
the phone to dial in and for the
suspense to build up hello dr. les Laura
ok so moving on um I mean that it is
there a way to mute this can you please
mute your side dr. Ellis oral okay I
believe it's me dude thank you so
okay I think we're good so one of the
things I would like to just define
upfront is what what do I mean by
cognition and team cognition cognition
refers to an individual's capacity to
perceive understand make decisions and
act upon their environment team
cognition refers to the cognitive
activities that occur at the team level
this is a bit of a general definition at
this point but I'll get into more detail
of what that actually means suffice it
to say team cognition depends upon this
phenomenon by which this theory that
cognition can be externalized that is I
can say or write something down from my
own mental models and then you can read
and understand it and incorporate it
into your own mental models so one of
the things I wanted to do first was to
take a look at how teamwork our teams
are typically assessed in the clinical
environment so just as a broad overview
I looked at a couple of systematic
reviews of different studies measuring
teamwork in the surgical environment
checklists are used to coordinate
activities this is because a number of
researchers have found that teamwork in
particular communication or lack thereof
has contributed to certain types of
surgical errors such as wrong side wrong
side operations now these studies are
have typically been evaluated using
using different person using instruments
that assess the perception of teamwork
or by analyzing the number of
communications or the number of
disruptions that our current
communication now in terms of internal
medicine just as a general assessment
team work has been measured through
a couple of different instruments many
of them are either subjective
assessments a team work where people
rate how good they feel teamwork is
usually before and after a training
event hello and a few of them assess
skills in terms of communication skills
how many how often do they explain you
know the events that are going on during
a surgery how often do they perform
closed feedback communication and do
they have the requisite knowledge to
perform their task and in the emergency
medical setting they evaluate teamwork
by looking particularly looking at hand
over events and they look at the the
quality and the content of information
that the quality and the content of
information that is transferred from one
person to another now one thing that
I've observed through these articles is
that there's a large number of
instruments that are used to a large
number of instruments in a variety of
techniques that are used to measure
teamwork but they also tend to depend on
usually a similar set of techniques that
are based on a subjective perception of
teamwork rather than a direct
measurement of the team's behaviors so
what I wanted to do was to use team
cognition as a theoretical framework for
organizing and developing measured
different measures of teamwork and
assessing their relationship with team
performance so as part of my main
theoretical question one of the things I
want to ask is okay how can we measure
team cognition in a clinical activity
system and I want to do this through to
Ames one is to simply describe how
cognition is distributed in an emergency
medical service team as they're
performing
a number of tasks in a simulated
environment and the second is to measure
the different properties of team
cognition based on techniques that have
based on constructs that have been
constructs and techniques that have been
identified by other researchers and also
to develop a couple of new techniques
where necessary so it in terms of
actually applying these different
theories of in terms of applying cognate
cognition as a theoretical perspective
for measuring team behaviors there are
different theories that can actually
describe cognition at the individual
level and at the group level at the
individual team cognition has typically
been used to describe human behavior or
what goes on in the mind for individuals
and one of the more there are a couple
prominent models one of the most
prominent models is the human
information processing model which
describes a number of discrete and often
measurable components such as a
situational awareness memory attention
decision and decision-making that are
part of the human decision-making
process and it treats the human mind or
the human as an information processing
unit much like you at a computer another
significant theory of individual of
human cognition is also naturalistic
decision-making it's this notion that
humans make decisions do not necessarily
make decisions in this linear processing
method that you might see typically in a
laboratory but that they make that they
may behave differently in a naturalistic
setting particularly if you have a
fireman reacting to a burning building
they're not going to you know observe
the event go through all of their
options and then select which ones most
appropriate but they're going to react
in based on their past experiences and
the affordances that their environment
enables intact now moving on to now
there are a number of theories that have
attempted to extend cognition beyond the
individual and to explain sort of what
that actually means and the processes
that actually occur so within an
individual cognition there was this
notion of situational awareness or that
an individual has a certain amount of
knowledge about what's going on in their
environment this was developed by Micah
Endsley in the early 1990s and she
extended this theory to apply to teams
namely that teams can share their
situational awareness about a particular
event to accomplish their tasks what
this means is that they can be mutually
aware of their environment and that this
mutual awareness can enable them to
coordinate or accomplish their own tasks
specifically another theory of team
cognition is also this notion of
distributed cognition which was
developed by Edwin Hutchins it's this
notion that the cognition required to
perform a task is distributed across the
individuals and agents within a system
so for example suppose we are developing
a map of ohsu and we both frequent
different areas of the hospital I might
have a deep knowledge of what the big
building looks like but then someone who
works say in the NICU might be able to
draw that plan later we can then combine
those representations to make a more
complete map of what ohsu looks like
finally there is a newer perspective
that team cognition is formed up of both
the mental models and team processes by
which the individuals work together to
achieve a common goal this attempts to
incorporate different behaviors such as
communication and coordination
into the development of shared mental
models so in terms of actual
representation there are I've observed
that there are two dominant analytical
techniques or tools that are used to
represent cognition one of them is a
propositional network which attempts to
model the semantic content of groups
mental models and model the overlap
between them so a propositional network
is generated by interviewing your
subjects identifying key terms about the
things they attend to in their tasks and
then finding the overlap between the
subjects now there's also another model
that has typically been applied to
different frameworks such as the human
information processing model and which
is known as the decision ladder and the
decision ladder basically identifies the
series of cognitive steps that a person
or an individual goes through to to make
decisions about their task and this
occurs through roughly three main stages
of obtaining situational awareness
trying to use past knowledge to make
decision and review options to make
decisions about that situation and then
to try to move from an initial starting
state to an initial end to an end state
or a desired end state and perform the
action to achieve that one thing I
should mention is that decision letters
have been used in a team setting by or
different researchers have chained
decision letters together in a team
setting to show how group decisions are
linked together to perform a task in a
coordinated manner so one of the things
I would like to do as part of my aim one
is described how the how tasks are how
emergency medical service
are distributed amongst its members one
of the reasons I want to look at an
emergency medical service teams is that
they're relatively small they perform
well defined tasks and that these tasks
occur over a short observable timeframe
and also that they're co-located this
means that I can be present for a series
of events and observe the event observed
multiple events over a short period of
time to collect some data and it also
represents a rich and complicated
environment in which people are trying
to make risky disky decisions in a short
timeframe another thing is that i'll
also be looking at how these teams are
performing their tasks in a series of
simulations so one of the reasons to
look at simulations is you don't
interfere with patient care as which is
one good thing and another reason is
that we have more control over the
environment to specify what the task is
perform repetitive to wait for those
events to occur and and so on so in
terms of actually observing these events
i am partnering with dr. ghee and her
team of emergency medical service for
children staff they are already set up
to observe a series of emergency medical
service teams across the state of oregon
and they're planning to contact those
people soon and ask them to perform a
series of simulations so assuming so
they the doctor geese team plans to
observe about forty EMS teams which
consists of two paramedics and about
three to four firemen volunteer across
the Multnomah County
across Oregon these teams will
participate in for simulations two of
these cases are related to trauma and
two of these cases are related to
cardiac arrests and they're attempting
to manipulate different variables in
these cases to evaluate the impact of
different protocols and anxiety on team
performance so this has a couple of
implications for my study one is that as
a pro the as a pro a lot of the data
collection is set up for me but as a con
I'm not able to test specific hypothesis
hypotheses due to the design of the
study but i think that the environment
will still provide a rich enough set of
data for me to explore applying
different measures of team cognition in
each of these simulations we plan to
have the the teams be dispatched to a
setting spend about ten minutes
responding to the case in treating the
patient ten minutes to well ten minutes
to travel to the scene 10 minutes to
treat the patient 10 minutes to travel
from the scene and transport the patient
to an advanced care facility and about
15 minutes for a debrief interview in
which they will be investigating the
different decisions that led up to
particular errors I believe the debrief
interview will use the critic will
analyze the critical decisions of the
invent that led up to certain errors
particularly the cues and the actions
that occurred finally the data will be
collected through a number of different
instruments primarily a set of GoPro
cameras eye tracking glasses which
tracks both I've movement and the
the target scene at which the
participants are viewing the debrief
interviews will be recorded through a
recording device and these events will
be transcribed so and also these events
will be observed by subject matter
experts who will score the team's
performance along various criteria such
as a CPR management airway management
number of errors of their clinical team
work and so on so one of the ways in
which I want to analyze this data is I
want to organize the event I want to use
decision letters as an analytical tool
to demonstrate how the cognitive tasks
are distributed between the different
members within the team so the decision
letter has a number of boxes to fill
this can be simplified as I mentioned in
two three three basic components which
is a situational awareness of the
initial starting state the analysis of
the options for responding to that
starting state and the execution of the
task to transition to a desired end
state now if we're dealing with
experienced participants or subjects
they can actually just shunt their
activities by immediately recognizing a
scene and performing the desired action
without without considering the without
actually thinking too hard on it or
considering the different options and
weighing them so one of the things that
I did in thinking about applying
decision letters is I looked over some
previous videos of paramedics responding
to a seizure code and the reason I
wanted to do this was to understand how
well could decision letters be applied
to this particular setting
so one of the things i have here you
don't actually have to read it is the
multnomah protocol for responding to a
seizure case one of the things to notice
is that this is written out in a series
of steps and that it doesn't actually
describe how the tasks should be
distributed between the members and a
team so it's a normative description of
how seizure should be handled but in
terms of the actual execution of those
tasks those are left up to the expertise
of the paramedics so when I was
observing the paramedics responding to a
mock seizure code you know the the
paramedic would observe a seizing
patient and they would administer
midazolam to treat that seizure and
while they were doing that they were
communicating with their participation
and requested that person administer
oxygen so in this case that task was
this provides a brief example of how
that a brief simplified example of how
that task was distributed across two
members of a team now I would like to
apply this to the full set of
simulations and the full set of teams to
look at to identify you know patterns
and behavior in terms of how they
distribute their tasks and work in a
coordinated manner what I anticipate in
terms of the outcome is a map of team
behaviors and responding to these
particular simulations but more to the
point I want to use these descriptive
models to provide context for the
measurements that i'll be taking in name
too so as part of my second name what i
want to do is specify the properties of
team cognition i'll do that in the next
slide measure team cognition using
previously developed metrics and develop
alternative metric swear Nessus
to measure to measure some other
properties of team cognition and then to
develop and validate a regression model
of team cognition so at a broad level
there are two types of metrics or two
classes of metrics that I've observed
with regards to assessing team cognition
one is a knowledge-based approach and
one is an interaction a based approach
the knowledge based approach tends to
elicit the mental models of the subjects
and either measure the degree to which
the subjects are to which they provide
the similar answers or to which they
know one another's answers so one of the
earliest techniques of this was the
saga' approach developed by Micah
endsley in which she developed
situational requirements and probed
individuals to see task them what they
know about their environment this
technique has been extended to groups
and has been applied for the most part
retrospectively to ask participants what
they knew about the environment as they
were performing the task and then they
measure the agreement between those
participants this has also been used to
measure mutual awareness between
subjects in terms of what does one
subject believe another subject knows in
terms of what they were observing the
interaction approach attempts to measure
different types or forms of
communication as a representation of
team cognition for example how many
times have people communicated that they
perform closed feedback communication
were there any glitches or disruption in
that communication and what are the what
is the what is the topological feature
of that communication pattern or how
does communication flow through the
members of a group is it completely
linear is it does it form a completely
connected graph in that everyone talks
to everyone and then what does this mean
in terms of performance so
in terms of specific properties that are
that fall within these different
categories the different constructs I've
identified our situational awareness
mutual awareness interactions in terms
of communication coordination workload
organizational structure collective
intelligence and emotional intelligence
shared awareness focuses on whether the
participants know the same thing about
in the same way about their environment
that is they agree that this Apple is
red or that it's a windy day now mutual
awareness is a particular contract in
which people are attending to one
another and they're aware of what
another person is doing but they may not
necessarily be aware of what that person
is attending to interactions can take
the form of basic verbal communications
of whether two people talk to one
another coordination refers to whether
people are sharing resources workload
refers to for the most part how burdened
people are by their particular task
organizational structure refers to the
topology or how people are arranged both
physically and in relation and
organizationally within an environment
so if you might have a hierarchy in
which someone is a leader or follower
and there are these two other factors
which I recently discovered from a paper
in which Willie had all identified this
phenomenon known as collective
intelligence what she did is she applied
a battery of intelligence tests two
groups and identified a latent factor
which in which there were some latent
factor for group intelligence that was
actually distinct from individual
intelligence finally she found that
emotional emotional intelligence as
measured by the eyes test or people's
individual's abilities to perceive
emotion by just looking at the eyes was
correlated with this notion of
collective intelligence
so in terms of actual measurements the
the constructs that I want to focus on
our shared awareness mutual awareness
interactions coordination and workload
so in terms the way I plan to measure
workload is to measure coordination in
terms of the number of coordinated tests
or the number of times participants
within a simulation share resources so
for example if you have two paramedics
that are both looking at an EKG machine
to assess the patient's pulse and then
they both act on their own individuals
task than that represents a coordination
of a shared resource now communication
has actually been measured in a variety
of different ways one way is to simply
take the raw count of communication
other ways have been to look at the need
of communication or the rate of
communication which is the number of
communications over time McMillan took
two different in two different
approaches which was to measure both the
rate of communication and the efficiency
of communication in terms of the the
ratio of pushes to pulls so for example
if I'm sending information out or if I'm
not requesting information then that
implies a that implies a certain level
of efficiency in that I don't have to
ask what's going on from the other
person now one of the things that I
wanted to look at was different
techniques for measuring team awareness
now team awareness has typically been
measured by administering a series of
probes about the task to a set of
participants in asking what they know
about the situation and measuring
whether they agree now the simulations
are occurring in the simulations that I
plan to observe are occurring in quick
succession and it actually makes it a
bit prohibitive to
apply a complicated set of probes to
assess their awareness so and because i
also have a set of glasses tracking
their I'm oh I've movement I want to
attempt to apply a different indirect
measure of their shared situational
awareness namely I want to see if
there's some notion of coordinated gaze
fixations to see if they attend to the
same environmental objects within a
within the same time frame to see if
they're coordinating their activities
about certain aspects of the task other
measurements are other measurements that
have been applied to there's also a
mutual awareness in which mcmillan
looked at the percentage of agreement on
other members tasks now the way I want
to use this in terms of gays fixations
is to count the number of times
participants look at each other and try
to pay attention to one another's tasks
now this may need some tweaking because
this only represents one channel of
information and the paramedics can
attend to one another both visually and
acoustically so I may have to take that
into account as well as for workload
workload has typically been measured
using the NASA TLX score it's a set of
six questions which are used to ask
participants how how difficult do they
believe the work was and how burden do
they feel by the work and again the
constraints of the simulations make it
difficult to a administer a survey so
but the glasses also provide an
alternative measure of a workload in the
form of the index of cognitive activity
what that is what that is is them the
glasses actually measure the rapid
dilation of rapid pupil dilation and
interprets that as brain activity
that is a measure of cognitive load now
there are certain pros and cons to this
one nice thing is that we can measure
cognitive load con of this is that we
cannot necessarily associate that
cognitive load with the particular task
as people could be thinking about their
next birthday party er something like
that so the ways in which caught on the
ICA have been applied in terms of a team
setting as people of taking the
cumulative cognitive load as a measure
of overall team workload I would like to
do that but I would also like to try
something else in terms of looking at
the difference of cognitive load between
the participants and this would give me
a measure of the equalness or of the
equalness of cognitive load between the
participants namely is one person taking
on all the tasks at any given time or is
the cognitive load more evenly
distributed between the participants and
what implications does that have for
performance in terms of my outcome
measures i plan to look primarily at the
clinical teamwork scale and number of
errors there are other measurements that
are being taken as well in terms of time
to deliver epinephrine time to
compressions and the subject matter
experts assessment of airway CPR
medication and seen management I want to
focus on the clinical team works scale
to see if the measurements are
correlated with an expert's perception
of what teamwork is are of good or poor
teamwork and I want to use the number of
errors to see if it's actually
associated with performance the reason
I'm focusing on two measures is it that
if there are no errors and people are
performing their tasks with a high
degree of excellent then I can fall back
on the teamwork scale the clinical
teamwork scale was developed by dr. ghia
and her team it in which a subject
matter expert answers a series of likert
scale scoring the participants on
a number of different factors in terms
of overall performance communications
situational awareness decision-making
and roll responsibility these inch these
different categories tend to be scored
in to be scored and assessed
individually but I have seen a couple of
different papers just take the overall
median of of all of the scores combined
finally the particular constructs that
I'm focusing on our shared awareness and
mutual awareness interactions in terms
of communication coordination and
workload I plan to split the the day the
simulation data into a training and
testing set perform exploratory data
analysis to identify the factors that
are correlated with my outcomes metrics
and to validate to develop a regression
model and validate that regression model
on the test set so what I'm hoping to do
is from all this work is to develop a
model of distributed cognition within
EMS teams and a framework for describing
teams according to their joint cognitive
properties I plan to accomplish this by
delivering my proposal this month my
proposal defense this month perform data
collection over the next seven or so
months performed data analysis in the
following two months and write my
dissertation within six months after
that finally we've reached the end and I
would like to thank a number of people
including my advisory committee dr.
Gorman dr. Agee dr. lezaroth dr. Mohan
and dr. Vukovic for providing me
feedback and for a number of demise
faculty for also for helping me through
this including at Diana Diana and Andrea
and lynn 4
me through various logistics and for
various colleagues such as James for
listening to me proud along yes and I
would also like to thank the NLM for
providing me funding to do this project
thank you and I will take questions now
yes all these years you'd think of the
tracking glasses yeah those are going to
be recording video of the scene that the
wearer is wearing and then also a little
overlay a little point of what part of
the scene they were looking at it so are
you going to be automatically analyzing
this data I am sadly going to be sitting
in front of a computer screen and coding
that data so the question of how you're
going to develop your coding schema and
do you know what you're looking for so
in terms of the quantitative analysis I
just want to develop I just want to code
into the physical object that they're
looking at and the time frame that
they're looking at I don't think I'll
need so i think that in terms of the
qualitative analysis i will need some
form of external validation and i would
like to ask some folks on the ems team
if they have time for that i did not
have plans for doing it for the
quantitative analysis because it seemed
pretty self-explanatory they're looking
at a chair they're looking at a books
the gaze is focused on that I see you
have your eyebrows raised so I i do just
because i can see that going off the
rails quickly and i think a lot would
depend on the resolution that they get
out of the goggles um if they're looking
at this package of equipment versus of
the package equipment six inches to the
left is it can be able to distinguish
that that might not matter so I would
because their way you can pilot test
that I think we have looked at it in a
private setting and it actually looks to
be fairly accurate cool so yeah um
anyone else yes
thank you nice presentation thank you
the question is what's going to be your
role during the simulation you've got a
distributor team that's coming together
for an emergency so my role is to
hopefully stay out of the way and take
observational notes but where are you
going to be my primary team member so I
plan to be there in attendance and i
plan to observe a lot of the data
collection will occur without my a lot
of the video of data collection will
occur without my without my without a so
but i will be analyzing that data
collection afterwards there will be
subject matter experts who will be
performing the debrief interview i think
that this is actually appropriate as
they'll be able to focus in on the
particular elements of the simulation
where they're not they're not proceeding
according to standard practice or not so
thank you Dan this is not a personal
very very interesting topic so some of
the stuff I've read though tricking the
aviation yeah that's actually a lot of
where I'm drawing my right I recognize
that come to but they rely heavily on
oral meaning sound cues hmm how are you
tracking those and bringing them into
your analysis mmm that's actually a good
question that I haven't thought about
yet and that one I'm so I think that if
I were trekking aural cues it would
happen primarily when attempting to
measure different forms of situational
awareness and i'll have to look at the
data to see whether i can or cannot
incorporate that because I think if I'm
observing someone performing
ask and they hear something there may be
no obvious evidence that they've heard
something or that I can you know see
that they've actually heard it I mean I
can do that with the tracking glasses i
can say that a sound occurred in the
environment i may be able to infer that
they heard it by their subsequent set of
actions but i won't but if they don't
sort of exhibit any outward change in
behavior i won't necessarily know if
they if they heard those cues so i'm not
sure yet whether or not i want to
incorporate them within the scope of my
analysis and that may just be a
limitation in my approach to the problem
so yes did i understand that part of
this would be recorded and transcribed
so would you actually have a
transcription of the entire process or
just of the interviews afterwards so I
believe the interviews are being
transcribed the I'll have docs
yeah well even then I'm not sure how
well that would help because I would
have I would still identify that someone
emitted a vocal or audio cue but I still
won't be able to identify whether it was
heard and I think that's kind of a
tricky thing to measure yes so you you
have you have GoPros which would you be
having those for example to be on the
ambulance driver on route to the scene
and yellow and so you would be able to
exchange to record the communications
that are occurring on row yeah yeah I
think that's the reason they're there
I would you clarify your thinking or
expand on your thinking a little bit for
the focus on errors as the key indicator
or a key method by which you assess
cognition of the team I don't quite
follow why that would be and maybe you
didn't mean to suggest that you would
only be so I think well I did say that I
was primarily focusing on errors because
I think that airs tend to be sort of a
standard metric used in health care
because people want to reduce errors end
one of the reasons is because you know
glitches are particular configurations
in team communication or team
interaction may result in errors in
which an individual has a mental model
that is not necessarily consistent with
what's going on in the environment there
is actual there's actually a contrast so
I think one of the reasons I wanted to
look at errors is that errors represent
a particular deviation and behavior that
will be able to describe and observe and
identify the root cause of and I think
that if we identify the root cause and
see if its associated or not with team
interactions that that would be
informative them some aspect of team
cognition right so I guess I would just
suggested in in the sense that you want
to establish a more general theory
da'kel framework yeah which would you
indicated that you might want to give
thought to two more broadly you know so
looking beyond simple errors as the
measure of that is true cognition well I
think that's also I think it's a bit
tricky coming up with a generalized
performance metric for a particular task
because any performance
will naturally be molded to the task I
think in terms of having a generalized
score performance the clinical team work
skill most closely approximates that
because it is an expert's assessment of
whether the team performed well or
whether they did not so I think that in
the event that errors may not be more
informative I think a subject matters
expert assessment on whether the team
performs well in their simulation
actually be more formative yes to just
22 comments really quickly one of which
it sounds like you're going to have
video tapes yes of the teams and that
one possibility P is to go in and
annotate the video tapes as well hmm
yeah I was actually planning to this
okay and have you good idea how long it
takes to do that yeah yeah I actually do
on that paramedic video I was annotating
took me about two hours to annotate 10
minutes so yes so that they're so yes so
what you but actually I was transcribing
that video not simply annotating it so
one suggestion for you is you might want
to take because you're going to have a
large number yeah to a propulsive
sampling of the videos videos and then
say so what differentiates okay a
high-performing team versus a poor
performing team as measuring the scores
mm-hmm okay the illustrators might have
is that you might consider in addition
to the teamwork score which actually
looks like its behavior based like do we
have East you talked about communication
behaviors and yeah a lot of I would
almost call the underpinnings yeah but
the question is do we get the guy to the
hospital within three minutes or to take
us an hour you might want to try and
look at the type of thing to and mate
see there is a point well that may
actually be kind of tricky because I
think that I mean it sounds promising
but in some respects the
II the events the events may occur
within a fixed time frame meaning okay
you do CPR for two minutes as part of
protocol and if that doesn't work like
get them to the hospital okay but your
metrics could be for example how longs
it take you to get the favor later to
the scene ah there was one at there so I
water time tap and efrain yeah so tell
time to get Bradford how long does it
take for you to complete the initial
assessment how long you know so it's
that type of thing that can be destroyed
by a bad team work and so i might just
suggest as you might want to look at dr.
gordon and dr. Keyes satori and see if
you can come up with some non
behaviorally driven metric of
performance oh yeah more like us you
know what's the box score and then then
we can look at what the RBI was or
whatever was below okay that's actually
a really good idea thank you okay
so I don't think the roles are assigned
a priority but that they may occur
naturally as a product of that team
having worked before or maybe even
spontaneously just because one person's
more inclined to take a leadership role
I think that's an interesting question
because that may actually help that may
actually show up in terms of the
descriptive models is how does someone
take leadership and then you know how
does that manifest in terms of their
delegation of tasks to their partners
and what happens when they're attempting
to take a leadership role with someone
they don't know is there some kind of
conflict which or not I think that it'll
be an interesting thing to observe and
see how it emerges but that the roles
are not assigned a priority in that
they're going to occur naturally okay
how this relates to a TLS training pls
training because from my experience from
doing those type of training and working
under those notables you have assigned
positions in the team fight the reason
either this another so positions are
quite fixed hmm I mean things young can
I mean things cannot happen outside what
the protocol dictates if you do that
you're not doing pulse you're not doing
a deal what do is have a girl so it's
very strict what you supposed to do I
don't know how that relates to this I I
would argue yes and no so that's how
first that's how the folks are trained
but second I think that that's how
they're trained in light of a pre
structured event that is supposed to
occur but the teams may behave
differently when they're confronted with
an event they're not familiar with so if
there's a certain amount of uncertainty
and a limited time frame they may behave
in a different manner yes by the English
simulation that's not supposed to happen
you're entering the simulation where you
yes again I don't know this but in a
here is it say these are your positions
you understand your passat you go inside
you might not know what you're going to
face but you know what you look what
your roles so let me ask you a question
when you're doing that acls training
what is the setting are you doing it in
a hospital my case yes I know they do it
in school so the distinction between
that and the cases we're working with is
that we're actually setting up different
sites that people travel to so there may
be certain constraints of the
environment that determine how the
paramedics and the firemen behave and
that may alter their behavior or they
may act in a very structured in
predetermined way if that happens then I
think what the evidence will show is
that there's no
difference across teams and I think that
that would be very interesting also so I
yeah I think it would probably not bode
well for my attempt to measure and
assess differences across teams but it
may be interesting to see the impact
teams have on normal or the impact
certain training has on normalizing
behavior to a very rigid extent so yeah
we're working with professionals who are
active paramedics and firemen yeah yeah
so their experience yes do you plan on
gaining any domain knowledge and basic
or advanced life support yes yes so if
yes or no how do you anticipate so our
knowledge to impact your interpretation
of the results mmm or tricky one so I'm
going to so the way I was planning on
doing it was I was going to pick up a
couple of books and attend and observe
the courses to see how folks are trained
what I anticipate is that this would
give me a normative model of how they
should behave and this would allow me to
contrast it with how they actually
behave in the wild so i'm mostly looking
for differences between how I think they
should behave and how I actually observe
they behave anyone else another question
so one of the issues you could
potentially face is that there are
significant differences in the training
given two different EMS people mm-hmm
like Seattle for example has a pretty
rigorous to your course you come out of
it you're making a hundred and forty
thousand a year yeah versus other places
it's much much less rigorous okay so how
are you going to account for that so I'm
yes okay so so so actually in Portland
we're lucky all of the people that
respond are paramedics so they all have
a level of training at the level at the
highest possible level of paramedic so
the only part that would vary in this
case would be the amount of experience
they have that the good side of that is
that we are doing pediatric emergencies
which are so rare that even the most
experienced person doesn't have a ton of
experience which is why we're doing this
study and looking at errors and safety
and teamwork and things like that
because while they could do a CLS in
their sleep and they can resuscitate
adults what we're finding is their
ability to apply that it it isn't good
to take a dolt and then apply it to kids
and then there's kids that are babies
and kids that are elementary and then
there's kids that are getting closer to
adult and so that variation also is
something where there are decision
points in their mind and that's why this
becomes so important is because it's not
quite as clear they are having to make
decisions first on which path do they go
what do I have in front of me and where
do i have go and they're all trying to
do that for something that they don't
seem very often ok I think I just heard
from you is that you have you're pulling
from one podium point for the Portland
as opposed to point from Portland in
Lane County which are extremely
different so we're doing
and there's a structure you all okay
sounds good well thank you